big congrats to kerry washington for
receiving four emmy nominations
including one for
lead actress in a limited series or
movie for little fires everywhere
but before those big honors i spoke to
her about another passion project
that is near and dear to her heart kerry
okay so this is a really important kind
of
issue to shed i think there's some
confusion about how much work is done
by the aclu i keep calling them like
real life avengers they're like rock
stars and when we were at sundance
that started happening like people were
anonymously paying for their lunch
because they were so
inspired by these lawyers in the film in
carrie's new documentary the fight out
tomorrow
cameras follow aclu lawyers fighting for
issues like gender equality
reproductive rights and immigration
i think we have to be fighting for all
of us to be
seen and to matter in a society in our
society i interviewed this busy 43 year
old mom of two at home
in front of her moma aka museum of mom
art
right now carrie is all over tv telling
incredibly timely stories about race in
america
you had good choices options
that being rich and white and entitled
gave you
from hulu's little fires everywhere to
the netflix film american son
am i have kids too do you okay i do do
you have any black sons
this big i think we are having a lot of
cultural changes for me it's really
exciting to be
um sort of telling stories championing
narratives that allow for marginalized
people to be at the center of stories